what is Kevin's relationship with Monti
Kevin Hart and Monte acai bhaag had a
brief intimate relationship about a
month ago in Las Vegas she met him
unexpectedly on the way to Las Vegas and
they had a brief intimate relationship
for a few days she's saying that she had
nothing to do with the recording of this
and she is not an extortionist when did
she learn about this tape Monte is
adamant that she had nothing to do with
this and that she is a crime victim just
like Kevin Hart is she first learned
about this online from news reports she
had no idea she was being recorded she
did not see any recording device she
didn't was not contacted by anybody and
there was no one in cahoots with her
exactly she did not even know she was
going to be meeting Kevin Hart in Las
Vegas so she certainly didn't plan
anything the only device she had was her
own iPhone which is actually in some of
the photos so you can tell clearly it
was not her phone that was doing the
recording to be clear she did not see
any devices in the room she did not
hearing noises of recording she had
absolutely no idea she was being
recorded and she's been appalled and
disgusted to see pictures of herself
from those secret recordings all over
the Internet was she contacted by the
extortionists or has she been contacted
by anyone else she has not been
contacted by the extortionist and we
don't know who the extortionist is has
she had a chance to see the video
well I she has looked at the videos and
the images and I have as well and
there's a number of disturbing things
one is that there are different camera
angles so perhaps there were multiple
cameras there's some fuzzy grainy images
so we don't know that's why we're going
to go to law enforcement it was there
anything that surprised you or shocked
you about the tape well it seems to me
that there was at least one fixed camera
in the room perhaps built into an
electrical outlet or something in the
wall of the hotel room you know this is
very disturbing I think to anybody who
goes to hotel rooms to think that
somebody could have a secret camera and
they're recording you it's a very
private place where many people are
intimate or take off their clothes and
it's shocking to think that somebody
could do that no Kevin has said that he
is cooperating with law enforcement you
say there's no evidence of that have you
reached out to his camp to see if they
are doing anything with lawn
foresman we have no reason to believe
that law enforcement is doing anything
at this point monte ax has not heard
anything Kevin Hart's team certainly has
her contact information and she has not
been contacted I'm not saying his team
never contacted her I'm saying law
enforcement never contacted Erin Andrews
had a very high profile case where
someone snuck a small camera in there do
you feel like this is the same kind of
thing where someone was targeting Kevin
well it's very possible I would be
guessing because of course I don't know
but it certainly seems like somebody was
targeting Kevin Hart and probably knew
that he was in that hotel room
you